So finally, let's take a look at what kinds of consistency are there. We
know that there is sequential consistency, and
then, there is a family of relaxed consistency
models which are allowed to violate one or more of those ordering rules. And the
models that have actually been proposed and
sometimes used, are called weak consistency, processor consistency,
release consistency, lazy release consistency, scope
consistency, etcetera. There are actually many,
many relax consistency models, too many to actually explain here. But the key
to all of them, is that although they allow arbitrary reordering's or
maybe some reordering's among data operations.
All of them support synchronization operations that
allow you to ensure that the ordering that you really want in your program, gets
to happen. Some of them do it by doing something like the N-sync corporation,
some of them do it by using
more refined memory synchronization operations. Some of them
do it by actually calling library functions
that are ensuring such ordering, and so on.